major changes at the White House
President Trump is shaking up his
communications team and just hours later
he they had to deal with a new blow in
the widening Russia investigation on
Friday White House press secretary Sean
Spicer announced his resignation
Anthony Skaar Moochie a Wall Street
veteran and TV commentator is taking
over the role as White House
communications director while Sarah
Huckabee Sanders will take over Spicer's
job as press secretary the shake-up
comes as more questions are being raised
by the Washington Post about Attorney
General Jeff Sessions contacts with
Russia in an early morning tweet the
president writes a new intelligence leak
from the Amazon Washington Post this
time against AG Jeff Sessions these
illegal leaks like commis must stop a
busy weekend already Paula Reid begins
our coverage in Norfolk Virginia where
the president will commission the Navy's
newest nuclear-powered aircraft carrier
Paula good morning good morning it has
been a tumultuous week for the White
House team the president publicly
criticized his Attorney General and lost
two members of his personal legal team
this all came amid a big shake-up in his
press shop leaving the new press
secretary scrambling for answers
the president has absolutely nothing to
do with any of the allegations that are
being made I think he's maintained that
the newly appointed press secretary said
the president is ready to put the
Special Counsel investigation aside but
just a few hours later the Washington
Post reported that US intelligence
intercept show Attorney General Jeff
Sessions discussed campaign related
matters including policy issues
important to Moscow with the Russian
ambassador during the 2016 race the
Attorney General spokeswoman said
session stands by his previous testimony
that he never spoke with Russian
officials about interfering with a
campaign or election earlier this week
the president criticized sessions for
accusing himself from the Russia
investigation he should have told me
before he took the job and I would have
picked some
the new revelations about sessions come
as president Trump's legal team is
reportedly seeking new ways to discredit
the special counsel in charge of the
Russia investigation I can say that the
people that have been hired to roll
Hillary Clinton supporters the president
and his team have publicly undercut Bob
Muller's investigation for weeks this
first for attorneys are all Democrats
people should know what what folks past
and their motivations and their
political motivations are and the
president expressed frustration that the
expanding investigation is now reaching
into the president's personal and family
finances issuing this warning to Muller
I think that's a violation I look this
is about Russia but the special counsel
has a broad legal mandate to explore
quote any matters that arose or may
arise directly from the investigation it
would a fighter school on Capitol Hill
any White House effort to block Muller's
investigation was met with bipartisan
dismissal if he fired Bob more I think
he'd see it a a tremendous backlash
response from both Democrats but also
House Republicans my view is firing Bob
Muller without cause is a violation of
the rule of law the president's senior
White House adviser and son-in-law Jared
Kushner is expected to testify before
the Senate and House intelligence
committees but it'll be behind closed
doors the president's son Donald Trump
jr. and Paul Manafort have negotiated
deals to avoid testifying
for now Anthony Paula Reid in Norfolk
Virginia thanks